- Journal note to self.
Dear reader, follow the North Star.
Erratic remnants of starlight
sends uniform rooftops
within a five block radius.
Adjusting our lens further down
into the scope of an urban city,
outlines of humans mechanized
by social structures
disappear into a hole in
the ground and are erased.
Calibrating the audio reveals
decompressing diesel brakes
trudging up the Upper West Side.
Car engines idling even (indistinct)
selling The Times across from the bodega.
Location only matters
because of conditions
that create location.
We discourse in dualism,
operating under the assumption
conditions run parallel.
That space entry relates
through distant memory,
Langston and Gwendolyn (indistinct).
Hear the echo on the overground railroad,
part metaphor, part homage to Harriet,
who would've freed more
if they'd have known
they were in bondage.
Perhaps we can be new millennium Harriets,
create renegade languages,
rescuing status quo from language bondage
as in them shackled
and don't even know it.
Traveling through black spat night,
snaking around corners into new corners
refusing a final destination.
__ through the train,
synthetic glass plane.
125th Street in block lettering.
America appears over the left breastplate
of a man in solid blue dress,
uniformity along the aisles.
Everybody facing north as
if something unknown awaits.
"Amazing Grace," the
homeless man in the corner
with his hand cupped for change belts.
How sweet the sound no
one hears, only the drone.
Because Hook doesn't exist,
2009, Harlem, New York.
Answer the phone at 10:00 P.M.
Offer a reserved "hello"
on a nebulous night filled
with pallid snow in Harlem.
Respond with, "Okay."
Listen, be attentive when you learn
he died in a hail of gunfire
at the intersection of Minnesota Avenue
and East Capital Streets
in the nation's capital.
After thinking, "That's f**ed up,"
thank your old college
roommate for calling.
Ignore that he greeted you as Hook,
the nickname you went by in the streets.
Hang up.
You can and can't believe
the truth simultaneously.
Write D-I-S-C-O in your leather journal.
Maybe this will immortalize the image.
You will never forget him,
but you have already forgotten Hook.
Before the black birds' echo bangs
against your windowsill, wake up.
Go directly to the mahogany
desk between two windows,
sit in the brown swivel
chair, stare at the building
opposite your building.
Rearrange papers that don't
need rearranging twice.
Open your journal to the name
written last night. Disco.
Remember the steel doors opening up
after being closed for 18
months for three felonies
in Fairfax County Adult Detention Center.
Five hours after that release,
see Disco wheeling an
ATM through your basement
on a hand cart.
Out of the wall with metal
chain and pick up truck,
he had pulled the money machine.
He did that.
This is your introduction.
Turn on the computer.
Type Theodore Blanford in the search box.
Click the magnifying glass,
expect to be surprised,
even though you know what
the results will bring.
Don't be surprised when
you scroll to Maryland
double homicide suspect
shot, killed in D.C.
One lone bird outside your
window flies backwards
at an indeterminate rate of speed
while the world moves forward.
The bird is red.
Look for balance in the oddity.
Note that double homicide
is five syllables.
Five deliberate pauses before, "Damn."
Remember you knew the
suspect, shooter, killer.
Suspend court in your imagination.
Add four indeterminate words
to formulate the phrase
"hold court in the streets."
This is how he would die:
holding court in the streets.
Prophetic.
After reading that the now-deceased wife
had wanted a divorce, deduce
it was because of drugs.
Visualize the wife and
sister just before death
in their doublewide.
Try to make sense of the
blood spilled on the carpet.
The red is deafening. Scream.
Wait for the buzz to stop buzzing
because someone rang the wrong buzzer.
There is always an echo after the buzzing.
Even after it buzzes
again, don't answer it.
It is not for you.
Keep reading the online article,
but more specifically the
phrases forcible entry
and protective order.
Acknowledge that your friend was a suspect
in his first wife's murder, too.
A dead body in the trunk.
Two days later, while
driving to school to teach,
call Short Man, because it takes that long
to find someone to talk about tragedy.
Tell Short Man, who is a
barber and has ten years
of razor tucked behind
his memory, what happened.
Agree in unison that prison
will turn the brain into a hum.
Agreeing again that prison taught you
to be a better criminal,
though you both digress.
Both of you understand the term anomaly
but it meant that Disco was a composite
of many men who never learned to be a man.
You will then ask the question
for the first time. Why?
Return back home from New Haven
before rush hour begins to bottleneck
the Cross County Parkway,
dig through the closet for the
first version of your memoir.
Disco rolled the safe out
of the department store,
the first line of the paragraph read.
Go to the next page where he loves to pull
the trigger of a gun more
than the torso of a woman.
Flip to the page where he and his sister
distribute lead bullets
through the windshield
and the impressions of circular holes
when the discarded lead
pierces the glass of Swift.
Pronounced. The body is a question mark.
He tried to run over
the wife with his truck
and then threatened
her with a claw hammer,
she told the police,
Ask yourself why this sign
didn't signify violence.
What theory would Ferdinand de Saussure
classify this under?
Put the manuscript back in the closet.
Don't beat yourself up because
you knew he was a killer
and said nothing to nobody.
Forget the double negative
your mom would correct you on,
and tell yourself it's
nature versus nurture.
Justify your silence in
saying that the world
you once lived in was filled
with silence and mayhem.
That is why they called you Hook.
Don't block Audre Lorde's
"Your Silence Will Not
Protect You" from your mind.
Pretend this is penance.
Wake up the next morning,
go back to the computer,
press any key to erase the black screen,
ignore the black birds outside your window
while telling yourself,
"This is the last time.
You need to forget.
But before you do, one more search."
Click inmate violent death in the news.
A flood of black birds
appear suspended in animation
at the top right corner of the webpage.
Ignore them, but then don't.
Tell yourself this is not
karma, Edgar Allen Poe style.
He did not want her to leave.
She wanted him to go,
said he needed treatment.
Think back to the 12-Step literature
that cautions about the 13th step,
sexual fraternization with
people inside the circle.
Feel confident in assuming that
she was a recovering addict
and understood addictive behavior.
Two addicts don't make a right.
Tell yourself this.
Read about the interaction with police
who failed to notice the inevitable.
Admit the judicial system
is failing to protect women.
"I am victim" was
tattooed on her forehead,
yet she remained invisible
to the patriarchs,
the ones sworn to protect and serve.
Ask yourself, "Does his death matter more
than the victim's death?"
Convince yourself that
race never stops running.
That memory will eat your ass alive.
Say "I am a changed man,"
but no one will hear you.
Get back in the bed, pull
the covers over your face.
Remember the dream. Forget hook.
Wake up tomorrow and feel guilty again.
- [Robert] Thank you for that.
(audience claps)
- And so that was a piece I
read from my first memoir.
It's called "Hook."
And it's really, we talked
about incarceration of women,
which is the most invisible
within what I call the inside.
I don't necessarily subscribe
to the notion of prison,
or ex-felon, or convict.
I don't necessarily believe
in that s**t as language.
'Cause I'm not an ex anything.
I'm not a felon. I'm just me.
You know what I mean?
So I think it's interesting sometimes.
However, I do get it.
When I'm in places like this,
I understand the things that...
If I'm about that work,
I have to put myself on
display a little bit.
So it's a negotiation.
But it's my negotiation,
and I determine the terms of when I...
You know what I'm saying?
So it is that, too.
But this is a book, it's epistolary,
but it's basically half me
and half a woman that was
incarcerated, named L,
in Brooklyn Detention Center, the Feds,
and she was detained for three
years in the federal system,
and we shared letters back and forth.
So this was actually my first memoir,
and then a lot of the things
that I kinda did in my life
come to her in mail calls,
so you actually read through her eyes.
And the main reason I did this
was because of the silence
and the absence of women voices
in this whole thing that we do.
Excuse me.
Yeah, I mean, we just heard that. Right?
So it's not hyperbole in that, you know,
go to these spaces, the least
represented at all times.
So I think, as I am a author,
but I'm not vain enough not to understand
what I'm doing with this language
is to sort of like give
people's voices too.
So she's part of my memoir
with that right there.
So I'm gonna read you a
little bit from "Dead Weight,"
which is my new one,
and it basically starts
off with a conversation
with Ralph Ellison's Invisible Man
on Riverside in New York.
And basically I'm talking
to the protagonist,
because I'm riffing off
of John Edgar Wideman,
who says minor characters
in someone else's melodrama.
And so what I like to think
about this whole thing sometimes
is how we become protagonists
in somebody else's melodrama.
And so I'm thinking
about the Invisible Man
and the protagonist, and
how our lives intersect
in very interesting and weird ways,
you know what I mean, through
time, as Black men, right?
So there's that.
But it's a long meditation,
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna read you
the beginning of it,
and then I'm gonna flip to a section
that sort of like gets at
the heart of where I grew up,
which is Alabama, in Birmingham,
a place which I really love
in all its complications.
I love that place, 'cause
it's my home, first of all,
but second of all, I like it
because people keep it real.
You know who you messing with.
Up here, somebody can be so...
Just because the N
word, you don't hear it,
doesn't mean it doesn't
live in the imagination.
The people that are
walking down the street
__, man.
And I find it very interesting
that people fail to recognize
that one single thing.
Feel me?
Anyway, "The Protagonist in
Somebody Else's Melodrama."
The ephemeral foliage to my left
blocking the picturesque
view from Riverside
is outlined by hemp dogbane,
hay-scented ferns, and golden Alexanders.
Before the riverbank's edge,
Virginia bluebells faintly
obscure the yellow water taxi
sputtering southbound toward
that section of lower Manhattan
resembling an upside-down middle finger
birding the Hudson on
the New York City map.
100 yards out over the river,
seagulls pipe unpredictable
trajectories in broken syntax,
often suspending themselves mid-sentence,
wading in the deaf caesura,
then freefalling backwards
into patterns of
descriptive sign language.
Two BMX riders with black bikes parallel
and identical in pedal rotation
rapidly approached before scuttling
southbound on the walkway to a muted blur,
unaware of their subtext of uniformity.
At 139th, vintage floodlights,
though not lit, are pronounced,
erect and lined single
file along the walkway.
A mother haphazardly waves
a wand of streaming bubbles
while her trailing son and daughter
play a game of catch-and-burst-the-bubble,
long before the game of life
bursts their innocuous state
and reality smashes into them head on
with the force of a Mack truck.
There is serene music in the background,
a loud congregation of finches
invisible within the trees,
their culminating voices singing
in perfect choral structures.
Diesel-engine buses join
the melodious overtone
with the stop and go of
their compression brakes
up and down Riverside.
Because it is mandated by the
New York City Parks Department
to clean up after your dog,
there are sporadic
flashes of pooper scoopers
bending down with plastic
bags to retrieve animal waste
deposited on the walkway.
A few more steps up the steep
incline is 145th street,
and the official entrance to
the Riverbank State Parkway,
its tall, perforated metal
sign bearing the park's name
in bright red letters,
accented by the wrought
iron gate painted green,
complete with the guard shack nearby.
Then the view to the left bends back
to the brackish blue water of the Hudson
before opening onto a canopy of trees,
as if the impending stretch of walkway
is the calm before the storm.
Dusk seems more than eager to descend
on this East Coast island,
and headlights will soon stab the darkness
while inching across the
bridge into New Jersey.
The smell of yesterday's
rain is crisp to inhale
with each elongated
stride along the walkway.
At 150th street, a small, oval-shaped park
has at its center a
15-foot-high, 10-foot-wide,
six-inch-thick bronze
sculpture by Elizabeth Catlett
resting on a raised bed of grass.
Carved out of the slab is
the silhouette of a man
who has no rib cage, or flesh, or veins.
His insides are cut out.
The silhouette holds his right
hand up, as if to say "stop,"
while the left is anchored to the side,
as if providing balance
against the turbulence
the world is capable of
inflicting, a sort of rudder.
Next to the monument is a concrete marker
inscribed with these words:
"I am an invisible man.
I am invisible, understand,
simply because people refuse to see me."
Behold Ralph Ellison's Invisible Man.
The silhouette, whom I
shall call Cutout Man
could represent me in various
stages of a complicated life,
at times unable to escape
the social pitfalls
that had befallen a slew of Black men,
particularly in the '80s,
an era that seems so damned archaic now.
The residual damage caused by drugs
and longs prison sentences,
however, is ever present.
I take a seat on one of
the curved benches nearby
and study my doppelganger in amazement
as spectator and
spectacle, fanatical-like,
thinking how easily the sculpture
of this timeless character
in somebody else's melodrama
sequestered an unimaginable
protagonist rendered real.
The unauthorized biographer of ours,
yes, mine and his, life trajectory
charted a path wrought
with racism, deception,
trickery, willful ambiguity, satire,
and comedic relief alongside
the theater of the absurd.
We were only made aware
of our line in society
through an accidental point of view.
That moment we were
able to reverse the lens
and peer into twisted eyes
connected to a brain that
dreamed a horrific fantasy
for which there seems no immediate escape.
Cutout Man and I fell
victim to a narrative
that featured us as the tragedy,
the sad sack, the bumbling idiot,
unable to control the thematic threads
within our own storyline.
We could not hear the
hidden or silent dialogue
that kept our daily existence simmering
below the surface of the living.
The only difference between
us is that I was born
not of the pen, but of the flesh.
Blood courses through my veins,
and I'm filled with bone and sinew,
yet my insides, too, are
invisible as a cutout.
I get up from my bench and position myself
so that I am looking
into Cutout Man's eyes
before he can split the scene.
On this day we are alone in New York City,
Hamilton Heights to be exact,
a rarity in the city of millions.
I have long held a
burning desire to dialogue
with this symbol of erasure
about the madness that
made both of us real.
This is my opportunity.
Although I am talking to myself,
I am talking to Cutout Man.
Today, he will be my therapist.
I can see straight through his body,
clear across the Hudson
to the Jersey shoreline.
He is a pattern, or a
figure traced and cut
from a human being, an
outline within an outline.
Let me switch a little bit
to one of the sections.
The other part is you're gonna catch me
talking to him in mid-conversation,
because it's really long,
but I wanted to get this one in.
And it deals with a situation
around James Baldwin,
that moment when you realize
that we in all this together.
So here we go.
Although Brown and Board of Education
were decided in 1954...
So I'm talking to him now, right?
We're going through this whole dialogue.
Some schools and districts waited
until the early 1970s to desegregate.
In Birmingham, Alabama,
oh, that magic city,
that glowing republic
of Southern Oligarchy,
compliance came in the waning hours
in the fall of '72.
This desegregation included
integrating teachers,
which brought me, the 10-year-old,
to the emphatic statement
about white people.
My mother and I entered
Gardendale Elementary
as a social experiment of integration
mandated by the Court,
and I would soon come to find
out what it meant to be black.
There's a wonderful video of James Baldwin
debating William F. Buckley at Cambridge
on the argument that the American dream
has been achieved at the
expense of the American Negro.
The event was hosted
by the Cambridge Union,
a student debating society, in 1965.
four years after my birth,
at the segregated South
Highlands Infirmary in Southside.
There is a moment about
18 minutes into the video,
and some of you may have seen this,
where Baldwin articulates:
"In the case of the American Negro,
born in that glittering republic,
and in the moment you are born,
since you don't know any better,
every stick and stone
and every face is white.
And since you have not yet seen a mirror,
you suppose that you are, too.
It comes as a great shock
around the age of five or six or seven
to discover that the flag
to which you have pledged allegiance,
along with everybody else,
has not pledged allegiance to you.
It comes as a great shock to discover that
as Gary Cooper is killing off the Indians,
and you are rooting for Gary Cooper,
that the Indians were you."
The thing is, Cutout Man,
before my entry into Gardendale,
every time I pledged
allegiance in the classroom,
it had been with kids who looked like me,
kids I learned to high-five, dap up,
and shoot marbles between
shotgun houses with
as we meandered into our teenage years.
Did you know that Tony
Morrison took the position that
something was lost in segregation?
The loss doesn't celebrate the
division the racism produced,
but what came out of that division:
a way of going against the grain
for the sake of self-survival,
taking the blackness forced upon you,
the nigga that you became,
and making it valuable,
something to be studied,
imitated, appropriated,
and commodified within
contemporary culture
for the sake of modern art.
Me and the kids I once
pledged allegiance with
were being conditioned
to blindly pledge loyalty
to a system we hadn't begun to understand,
nor had that system
pledged allegiance to us.
There had been dynamite blasts,
water hoses thrust upon the throngs,
billy club beatings, dog bites, hangings,
insurrections against humanity,
and violence right in our own city,
and yet, we remained oblivious
to our outer world of segregation,
encapsulated in our own sub-society
of a perceived otherness.
Maybe if we kids had been aware,
or if our parents had been more woke,
we all would've revolted
against this narrative,
or at least questioned this
insane allegiance to a society
not yet fully committed
to our best entrance.
And yes, I would watch the
old westerns with my father,
cheering for the cowboys
to do the Indians dirty.
Even outside playing with my friends
between the shotgun houses in Smithfield,
I strutted a six-shooter cap
gun, full with cowboys suit,
thinking I could be the Lone Ranger,
when in actuality, all
I could ever hope to be
was Tonto, a sidekick.
What Baldwin knew, and I didn't,
but would soon come to find out,
was that there is a terrifying moment
within one system of reality,
a moment that would contextualize race,
from which there is no return.
True, you do become the thing to be hunted
and treated like an animal.
The trauma is difficult to retell.
And remember, I begin slow,
meek. Then it happened.
"Say what? I can't hear
you, speak a little louder."
Cutout Man is pushing the
story out of my mouth.
"Don't hold back now.
Get it out, speak."
I come back again with,
"Then it happened."
"That's it. Now we're talking."
I continue with authority.
The ball was up in the air,
and Michael Hallmark, my
new best white friend,
had thrown the spiral
perfectly, and I was so fast,
I thought I would jump
high out my PF Flyers,
and then they were laced real tight.
I wanted to jump high, but
couldn't jump high enough,
because the ball was sailing too far
from my fingertips to reach it.
The ball hit a girl on her side.
I picked the ball up,
she kicked real hard,
called me "nigger", called me "nigger",
called me a "nigger."
And I punched her in her
mouth with my fist. Hard.
Red appeared on her face.
Red blood rolling down her white face.
She started crying. I started laughing.
I wanted to cry.
She called me a "nigger",
and I hit her real hard.
And it felt damned good.
Let me be clear.
Eunice Pearl Davis, now a Horton,
but daughter to Rosalie,
was never a timeout or a
stand-in-the-corner type mother.
My mother never hesitated
to give teachers full authorization
to paddle without parental consent
when deemed necessary.
I have no memory of how I
arrived at the principal's office
to wait for punishment.
Maybe it was the eerie
silence surrounding the event,
because the teachers
knew something I did not,
in terms of the history
related to Black boys
and white women in the South.
The memory of what transpired
after my arrival is clear.
Eunice Pearls comes into the office
and says to the principal
standing over me,
"Do not lay one hand on him."
Now when I say never, I mean never, ever,
did Eunice Pearl utter those
words in regard to punishment.
I knew then, in this racialized moment,
my response to an action
was bigger than the act.
But Baldwin knew that
there would come a time,
and that time had arrived.
It would take a few orbits around the sun
for me to understand the enormous weight,
the intensity of the primal scene
that could have taken my life.
Forget two years after
the 11-day segregation
from my mother, but then don't.
how on September 15th, 1963, a
Sunday morning dynamite blast
inside a church morphed four little girls
into a forever memory.
Forget Carol Denise McNair, but don't.
Forget Addie Mae Collins, but don't.
Forget Cynthia Wesley, but don't.
Forget Carole Robertson, but don't.
And don't forget Black boys.
There's always a lineage of Black boys
to draw context from too.
There had been Virgil Ware,
sitting on the handlebars
of his brother's bicycle,
who caught a bullet in the chest
from a shooter riding shotgun
on the back of a Confederate
flag-bearing motorbike.
The end result, face down in a ditch.
James Robinson, angered
by the church bombing,
because he had already experienced
a moment of race realization,
gunned down two hours after
the blast, in an alley.
And make no mistake,
the police account matters
more than the victim.
The usual responses came after the fact.
He lunged, reached, looked
suspicious, made a move.
They always flee.
The police fired in the
air, fired in self-defense,
because niggas be magical.
Niggas hang themselves by themselves,
turn water into wine,
slip out of handcuffs,
be looking like every other nigga,
do other niggas' time in jail,
real and imagined, make freedom
disappear in a finger snap,
or turn it into a life sentence.
Or worse yet, niggas get shot dead,
and the world changes
the television channel,
unbothered, unfettered, and unmoved.
My father who left work
with the ghost of Emmett Till on his mind
when he got the call from
Gardendale Elementary
that I had hit a white girl
would years later admit he had to go.
Had to.
He had to, because I was in
a place that didn't want me,
that said, "Hey, nigger" every day
to discourage me from falling in love
with their idea of beauty,
their idea of truth,
to never mistake blackness for whiteness
in terms of privilege.
The principal wanted integration,
was part of a movement in Birmingham
for equal education and access,
perhaps was a dreamer in
believing that all men
and women were created equal.
In his dream, he saw the need to protect
this little Black boy
from a fate all too clear
for Black boys who didn't stay in line.
The parents wanted blood, or neck,
and were not at all
happy their little girl,
with blood coagulating
on her face and lips,
got clocked in the mouth by a nigga.
But neither was the Black boy happy
at being called a "nigger",
so we sat in a conundrum.
In the end, the principal
sided with his gut,
the question being what I had done wrong.
What had I done wrong?
My parents taught me not to hate.
I did not call the girl trailer trash
or any other derogatory terms
I would come to know as an adult.
Perhaps the principal had no choice
if this social experiment
was going to have the opportunity to work.
But what about the
below-the-surface narrative
by those who often control the narrative,
whispering in the parents' ear,
"You know, he can go missing.
Done happened before.
Turn up in the Coosa River
with his face eaten by catfish."
I would never know how close
I came to being seen at sun up
with my neck snapped at Kelly Ingram Park,
hanging from a makeshift wooden cross.
I would go back to school the next day
like nothing happened,
that big ass-elephant
no one wanted to acknowledge in the room,
still present and accounted for.
The kids knew what had happened,
I knew what had happened,
yet not one of the adults
wanted to talk about it openly.
No one cared to ask me about
the trauma of the moment.
The fact that I hit a girl,
when all my life I had been told
that was the one thing to never, ever do.
After the accident,
I didn't associate with
the other kids in my class.
I only wanted to get as far away
from that racial madness
as humanly possible,
because it became evident these people
were incapable of being human.
I never saw the girl again.
Maybe her parents took her out of school,
unhappy at how white folks cared about
the fate of Black boys
in Jefferson County.
One thing I'm almost certain of,
and would love to confirm years later:
the little white girl never
called anyone a nigger again.
The next year, sixth grade,
I was strolling to an
all-Black Catholic school,
planted directly in the hood,
across the tracks in Titusville.
Thank God.
There would be bonding over
stacked heels and platforms,
circular Afros, and braided cornrows.
We drowned each other in
code-switching language
the way we say "mane" and "gull."
We didn't run from our own skin.
As a matter of fact, we
ran into it headfirst.
We were in a cocoon of blackness,
and whiteness had inverted to the other.
They were the others now.
And we called each other "nigga."
But it was love,
learning early in life
to take what is given
and turn it to something valued.
I had left hell and returned
to the mythological paradise,
if only for a moment.
And yet society would
not care about the scars,
the racial wounds bandaged up,
but would expect me to forgive those
who knew damned well what they were doing.
All right.
Y'all still with me?
(crowd claps)
All right. Okay.
Make sure you're with me.
Let's see where we're at here.
I think we'll stop right
here. We're gonna stop.
Let's do that.
I'll read one poem before
I go. How about that?
We talked about...
I heard someone was talking
about the book situation,
so I have a poem in here
called "Roxbury Correctional Book Club."
Basically, it talks about the way
we treat books on the inside.
And all of these reference
some kind of book
that references incarceration.
So the first one is in poetry,
and I'm thinking about Robert Hayden.
The second is memoir, Chester Himes.
The third one is fiction,
Mitchell Jackson, "Residue Years."
And the fourth one is Miguel
Pinero, "Short Eyes," right?
So here we go.
Now this is from 289-128,
which was my D.O.C. number,
so I figured I would take it back
and claim license over that.
289-128, property of the state.
"Roxbury Correctional Book Club."
One. Poetry.
American Journal arrives in a library cart
dog-eared to page 18,
"The Prisoner," as if to
start here in media res,
Dear Hayden: The I in me no longer lives.
It vanished, I confessed.
The collective We is no longer better.
Yes, walls here are gray, not green,
but know your poems sing.
Again, I does not exist, comrade. I do.
Between life and death
in this infinite space with no clock,
no markers of no time,
calendars to strike out the day or days,
running together after lock in.
I write.
The legal pad fills itself with regret.
Ownership is mine, even in this cage.
A brokenness dictated by time's torture.
Writs, habeas corpuses, motions denied.
In a house lacking doorknobs to turn.
Yes, the cockroach caught became a pet.
At Christmas, my celly snorted white lines
to escape physical torture of the mind,
cascading in and on
itself, rapid then slow.
A program of abstinence and madness.
Two. "Memoir for Old Skool."
Gloved fist, flashlight, baton is fair.
Entering the hole requires protocol,
ears, mouth, gums, arms, lift and reach,
bend over, spread each butt cheek.
Behold the steel holding cage that kills,
a metal mirror bolted to cinder block.
Old Skool stares at the refracted image,
age a natural antagonist of the young.
Forgotten brown face,
a little boy once someone
knew well decades before.
Life before puberty, before adulthood.
Every two years, hair turns grayer.
A nickel gone with no redemption song,
he will never know if change is real.
Computer shop, religion, G.E.D.,
college certificates, advocates, a degree,
none changed "The Quality of Hurt."
Old school is in the frame struggling.
On good days, he reads
Chester Himes's words
corroborating street heroics.
How else to define anecdotes of realism,
or the slow fatality of imprisonment?
The son cannot bear witness anymore.
Forget rope, lethal injection, or gunshot.
"Fiction."
Half-wet, the cigarette half-lit,
a Bugler roll up outside walking to chow,
a fine mist, picturesque and primeval.
Almost halfway until rain implodes
into baptismal for sinners,
so believe in uniformed
gods lining the walkway.
"The Residue Years," on loan from cell two
came last night, the paperback version,
bringing characters
like Champ here, inside.
A fool's dream, or set up by subtraction.
Too many pleas, illegal searches,
guilty at the thought
of life, though innocent
as the mirror shaded bureaucrats,
Dreaming family, I draw
wife, kid, dog in my head.
Time measures mathematics
that fail to reduce mandate to logic,
hidden in cells disguised as change.
The housing unit is an American
critique on full display,
cloaked in numb silence.
There are no empty skeletons on wheels,
with limbs pulled apart
by a team of horses.
The body is now instrument,
and tonight, a book might
save my life after lock in.
"Drama."
Anything can be destroyed.
For the skeptics, trust.
Donny was deflowered one
night after count time.
"Clearly the structure is obsolete,"
says Angela Davis,
and I sit in darkness, expected
to write about injustice.
A witness to nothing on the stand,
but in op-eds, I can be quite believable
with the unimaginable.
A report from cell 23. Irony or ironical?
I say truth, on what plainly
is a corrupted condition,
identical to the blueprint
overlooked within the
penal system you can't see.
The backdraft's flashpoint, a raging fire.
This suicide must be.
I must commit to killing the
I in order to save myself.
There's no hope for the flower.
Under the bolted metal door,
it appears sometimes one act at a time.
Short eyes.
The dramatic place slid from cold cement
from cell to cell.
Poet Miguel Pinero is one of a few.
Whoever gave us prisoners
us and our right,
society inverted.
Imagine that concept.
Color too.
This violation is only the
beginning of what you knew.
Come sit in the political
madness alongside the bad.
Perception versus the
real occurs quite quick.
Or, of course, crimes against Donny
occurred quite frequently.
All right.
Thank you.
(crowd clapping)
- Thank you.
- My pleasure.
Sorry about that.
- It cuts a lot of stuff off.
Thank you. Thank you.
I don't know how to follow that.
Well, I guess I'll start
with an introduction.
My name is Richard Rivera.
I'm the director of
academic reentry at Cornell.
I also do ethnographic work in Ithaca
among the homeless population.
I'm formerly incarcerated.
I served 39 years in Ingard Prison
in New York State, obviously.
But this whole event has me
thinking a lot about prisons.
And Focault's name was...
Is this working?
- [Organizer 1] I don't
think it's working.
- I think I turned it off.
- Yeah, it's on.
This one's on.
- [Organizer 2] Just go a little closer.
- A little closer? Like this close?
- [Organizer 1] Yeah.
- So Focault's name was
brought up a lot today.
And I think rightly so.
He's instrumental for us
to understand the disciplinary
technologies and practices
that produce and reproduce
the subjectivities
necessary for hegemonic state.
But when I think of prison,
I think it is more an
encounter with the absurd.
So I think about Camus,
I think about Heidegger,
Kierkegaard, because that is what it is.
It's an alien place where an individual
is trying to find themselves,
places that they don't understand,
friendships that they don't
know how to relate to,
and in a lot of case, this
is what happens in prison,
that struggle to try to find yourself
and define yourself in an environment
that's really hostile to you, right?
And that's where our literature
and our creativity comes from.
It's informed and defined
by our environment,
the scarcity of the environment,
the violence of the environment,
the way the prison life is structured,
as a hierarchical environment,
in which the individual
with the greatest propensity
for violence generally rules.
He doesn't have to have
an education, money,
or anything, that doesn't matter in there.
A sort of inverted hierarchy in prison,
where those individuals are.
But there are spaces that are created
especially for individuals in prison
that are trying to build their lives,
and one of those is the classroom.
I don't know if individuals
that teach in prison
know how important the
space is for prisoners.
A college classroom is a place where we go
and we can leave the
institutional life behind,
the prison life behind,
and where we can perform as scholars
and engage in a way that we
feel will not be disciplined,
and that is a tremendously
incredible space.
And a lot of times,
in trying to articulate
our experience in prison,
we sort of dress it in
codes, or in scholarship,
in order to get the word out,
and I think a lot of
times that what we get
is a filtered, fluffy
kind of representation
of what prison life is like.
And I wanted to make that point clear,
because my own experience was like that,
was where I constantly struggled
to try to understand my place
in the world, who I was,
and that was detrimental.
And I was able to navigate
my way through that
with the help of others
and some of the literature
that brothers produced.
There's this piece that
was produced by Yale,
Doolittle, called "Zo",
in which this individual Ivan Killgore,
who's a prisoner at I think California,
and he writes about
this experience, right?
He says, "Allow me to introduce myself."
He says, "Within these walls,
I am a socially dead person
whose existence has no
legitimacy whatsoever."
And I think this this
aptly describes the state
that most prisoners find themselves in,
and why finding ways
of expressing ourselves
through literature, art,
poetry is so essential
to who we wanna be and how
we wanna define ourselves.
He says "This reduction takes place
in language and culture,
typically beneath your
conscious awareness.
Like people, we get our strings pulled
by the forces and
circumstances they create,"
meaning the disciplinary state.
"They have no legitimacy whatsoever,
which is to say no self-respect
and no sense of self-worth."
He goes on to say, "Self-respect
and a sense of self-worth
is the innermost armament of our soul.
It lies at the heart of our
attempts to maintain humanness.
To be deprived of it is to be dehumanized,
to be cleaved from, cast below, mankind.
Dignity, needless to say, is
as essential to human life
as water, food, and oxygen.
Let me be clear.
In prison, degradation can
be as lethal as a bullet."
And and I have witnessed this.
I have witnessed
individuals be so beat down,
be so dehumanized,
with these microaggressions
and macroaggressions,
'cause there's a lot of
beatdowns in prison, too.
Or a women's prison where
hygienic products are used as ways
to dehumanize women,
denying them basic needs
or making them beg for it,
or manipulating it in some way
that a woman feels less than.
And it's the same thing with toilet paper.
I went to Kathy Boudin
memorial the other day,
and she wrote a piece,
a poem, I wish I had it,
about toilet paper, right?
And I myself witnessed this happen.
This guy who used to take
a lot of crap in prison,
take craps from the prisoners,
take craps from the COs,
be deprived of this, that, and the other.
And one day we're quiet on the company,
and he yells out to the CO,
"I need some toilet paper."
And the CO denies him the toilet paper.
You know, "I'm not gonna
give it to you," or whatever.
And this guy just went on a rampage.
He broke the sink, he broke the toilet,
they're made out of ceramic.
He threw his bed around.
He just snapped because of that simple...
And denial was the last straw.
That's the most he could take.
And after that he just kind
of became like a wild person.
But it's in the indignities compounded
that really make us question
our value and who we are.
And it is only through
art, through literature,
through writing, through
encounters with people
from higher educational programs,
or people that treat us like human beings,
that create these special spaces for us,
that we rediscover our humanity.
It is this practice through
academia that I believe
leads brothers to
survive this environment.
'Cause prison is about resistance,
and education, and writing, and literature
is a form of resistance in our way.
It's a way for us to express ourselves,
to give voices to ourselves,
even if it's fiction.
We always incorporate a
lot of ourselves in it.
Anybody who has taught in prison
and has received a essay from anyone
knows that a lot of
that guy's personal life
is involved in that paper.
He talks from firsthand experience,
because they wanna be heard and spoken to.
And I think that that is the form
of disturbing the status quo, right?
What we do in prison through
our educational programs
is a way of disturbing this,
is a way of gaining a little
power where they have none.
A story of mine is, I spent
a lot of time in the box.
I don't know if you could tell,
but I used to be like a wild guy.
So I spent about 12 and
a half years in the box.
And the box is punitive segregation.
Imagine it like this.
So it's a place where...
A jail within a jail, I think
somebody described it earlier.
Was it you? The jail within a jail?
Yes, yes.
And it is like that.
You go in there, they
take everything from you.
As soon as you go in,
they put you on a wall,
make you face the wall,
and take every piece of
clothing and hand it back.
Then you bend over, scoop over,
and do all the indignities that they want.
Then they'll put you in a cell,
and you've got three things going on.
You've got three meals a day,
you've got two showers a week.
Within 72 hours they're gonna let you
see your property to inventory,
and they're gonna give
you your legal work,
a pair of pants, a pair
of socks, an underwear,
a pair of slippers, that's it.
20 pictures and five books. That's it.
And these are the things that, in the box,
they use to control you.
This is what they control.
They control you with your
meals, they'll deny you this.
And my strategy when I go to the box
is that I don't talk to anyone.
I don't talk to the CO,
I don't take the food,
I don't do any of that.
My go-to move was going on hunger strikes.
So they'll put me in a cell,
and I'll just face the wall,
the CO's right there, and they'll come,
"Mr. Rivera, you want your food?
The nurse wants to see you.
Do you want your property?"
And this will go on for 40 days.
I'll go on like this for 40 days.
And you think, "What the hell
is this guy doing there?"
And that is a way, I think,
for me to gain power.
And I'm gonna tell you how.
'Cause in the box,
everything runs repetitively,
like a mechanical thing.
The COs make the rounds when
they're gonna make the rounds,
they bring the food when
they're gonna bring the food,
the captain comes around once a week,
or twice a week, or something like that.
And during this period
that I'm doing this,
all this becomes disturbed.
The CO starts announcing, "Cell
16 is not taking his food,"
and he'll do this repetitively.
The other prisoners start hearing,
calling my name, and I won't answer.
The captain will make
more frequent rounds.
The chaplain will end up there.
The depo security will end up there.
About 20 days into this protest,
one CO will come and say,
"Yo, I don't know why you're
doing that, but I respect you."
Because I drink water and I don't eat.
And by the time I finish
40 days, I have to stop,
because they've got a standing
order to force feed you
in 40 days in New York State.
And last time I lost 68 pounds doing this.
But by the time I finish,
they don't mess with my showers,
they don't mess with my food,
they give me the property like
they're supposed to give me,
they don't disrespect
prisoners next to me.
I sort of created a space.
I have disturbed the power
dynamics in that place.
I have gained a little power
where there's obviously none
in a system of total domination.
I think James Scott wrote an essay
called "Weapons of the Weak."
He doesn't mention the hunger strike,
but Bobby Sands and them
brothers (indistinct) did,
and that's where I got the idea from.
And these are the little
forms of resistance
that we could use sort of to disturb it,
and writing is one of them.
That was just a physical anecdote
about how power is disturbed.
But writing poetry is one of them.
Speaking, asserting yourself,
giving yourself a voice,
or finding the medium for your voice,
is a really powerful
tool to have in prison.
And I think higher educational
programs in prison do this.
And then we talk about
the subject of this,
which I want to bring it around,
the subject of this symposium,
imagination and incarceration.
When I heard that, like you,
I was struck by the singular of mind.
Was it you?
Somebody else mentioned
the singular of mind.
And I thought about how come
no one is speaking about
what informs the prisoner's
imagination, right?
And I think it is important to understand
that the prisoner's imagination
is informed by their
environment, of course,
by the cultural norms that
are developed in there,
by the economy, by the systems
of what I call prison life.
The environment in the yard,
where prisoners are making things happen
in an environment that's defined
by scarcity and violence.
So they'll have nine weight courts
and 1,100 prisoners that wanna work out.
And prisoners will fight for those courts.
They'll have at services only 40 people
allowed in the room at services.
So the other Christians or Muslims
will have to wait somewhere else.
Only 10% of the population is prison rich.
That means that they get
regular packages and food
and support from family,
and they sort of become
victims in a lot of sense,
or have to participate in
the black market in some way,
because this is the way the system is.
But this informs us.
So again, in the box, right?
In the box, we have 43
cells on the company.
They've got solid doors,
and I have a cigarette in one cell,
and this guy will have matches in 23 cell.
There's no porters out,
there's nothing happening.
So what do we do?
We take the toothpaste,
and we'll break it in half,
put wet toilet paper in there,
take our underwears, take the strings out,
tie it to the thing, and slide
it under the door real fast,
and it'll travel like 15, 20 cells.
And the guy will do the
same thing over there.
Or fixing a hot pot with a nail clipper.
I mean, the ingenuity and creativeness
that this environment produces
I think works its way into the way
we express ourselves creatively,
expresses in our writing,
in our codes that we switch.
So when a writer writes from prison,
he's actually speaking to two audiences.
He's speaking to you in a
way that you will understand,
but I know what he means
when he uses coded language.
There's a difference there.
And that got me thinking because of this,
but it also got me thinking because
the further I've moved away from prison,
the more I've been thinking about it.
And to end, I wanna read
a piece from Dwayne Betts.
I wanna honor the Dwayne
Betts. He's my boy.
And he writes a piece
here called "Confession,"
which I think speaks to that
getting closer to the prison
as you move further away,
and I think it's important.
All right, so it goes...
I'm gonna mess it up, 'cause
I know I'ma mess it up,
so you don't report it back to him.
- [Randall] No, I'ma tell him.
I'm gonna text him right now.
- You wanna read it for me?
- No, I'm just playing.
(Randall laughs)
I got him on speed dial.
- If I told her how often
that I thought of prison,
she would walk out.
She would walk out the door that leads
just as much to madness
as any home would desire.
She would walk out and never return.
My employers will call
me a liar and fire me.
My dreams are not all nightmares,
but this history has
turned my mind's landscape
into a dragoon.
I do not sing.
Have lied for so many months now
that truth Harbingers lost.
Sleeping beside her when a
memory is holding me tight,
as she did before the lies
turned everything into a battle.
I once gasped, and launched,
and tried to strangle the pillow
which she placed beneath my head.
Imagine me explaining that to her,
while still shivering like
a panicked and broken man.
I stopped believing in
God long before then.
But that night,
when outside there was
no light, but darkness,
I saw something of what
inevitable has touched me.
My children slept with their lights on.
I walked into their still lit room.
My son was asleep, and his
brother draped over his body
as if he were a pillow.
The way he loved his brother
was everything my time
in the cell denied me.
If I told my woman that
she would want to know
if I thought I deserve all that loss.
Her mother wonders why I won't let it go
and holds onto the happiness
and the life we have.
But how do I explain that
outside on nights like this
is where I first learned
just how violent I might be,
that I think of prison
because in all these years,
I still cannot pronounce
the name of my victim.
- [Randall] You done good, dog.
You done good.
I'ma give you kudos.
Five stars.
- Thank you.
(audience claps)
- [Randall] I'm definitely
gonna let him know.
(audience claps)
- If there's any questions...
(gentle music)